we're asked to graph the function f of X
is equal to negative 3x squared plus 8
so let's just try a couple of X values
and see what values f of X takes on for
each of those X values and then we can
plot them and and graph our function so
let me draw a little table here so this
is will be X and let's call this f of X
and we could set we could say set our Y
values to be equal to f of X so let's
say that X is equal to negative 2 and
I'm just picking these numbers
arbitrarily you could have picked
negative 3 you could have pick negative
1.5 I'm just picking numbers that are
relatively close to zero on both the
negative and the positive side and
numbers I like using the integers
because those are will be relatively
easy to work with much better than if I
was using something like negative PI or
negative 1.3 or something crazy like
that so these are just arbitrary points
that I'm sampling from the domain so we
can get the generalized shape of the of
in this case it's probably it's going to
be a curve the generalized shape of the
curve and then I can connect the dots so
when X is negative 2 what is f of X f of
X is negative 3 times negative 2 squared
plus 8 which is equal to negative 2
squared is positive 4 positive 4 times
negative 3 let me write this this
negative 3 times 4 plus 8 that's
negative 12 plus 8 which is equal to
negative 4 so the point negative 2
negative 4 is going to be on our graph
actually let me just start graphing it
so let me draw my I'll call this the
y-axis and I'm just going to set our Y
values whatever the output of our
function is so Y is equal to f of X and
then let me draw the x-axis so let me
draw the x-axis like this so let me draw
which I want to do it like this I'll
draw the x-axis like that so there's my
x-axis and I'm going to try the points X
is equal to negative 2 X is equal to
negative 1 X is equal to 0 X is equal to
1 and X is equal to 2 so this first
point over here to negative 4 and
actually let me graph that so let's say
that this right over here is negative 4
this would be positive
or and this would be positive eight so
the first point is negative two negative
four when X is negative two f of X when
the input entire function is negative 2
the output is negative 4 negative 2
negative 4 right over there that's the
point negative 2 comma negative 4 let's
do another one
what happens when X is equal to negative
1 then f of X is negative 3 times
negative 1 squared let me write it
negative 1 squared plus 8 negative 1
squared is just 1 so it becomes negative
3 plus 8 this is going to be equal to 5
so we have the point negative 1 5 on our
graph negative 1 5 is going to sit so
this would be 6 right over here so 5 is
going to be right over there so we have
negative 1 negative 1 5 is going to be
right over there negative 1 comma 5 and
then let's see what happens when X is
equal to 0 when X is equal to 0 f of X
is negative 3 times 0 squared plus 8
this part's just 0 so it's just equal
equals 8 so we have the point 0 8 0 8 is
right over there so that's 0 comma 8 and
then let's see what happens when we go
when x becomes positive 1 then you have
negative 3 times positive 1 squared plus
8 positive 1 squared is the same thing
as negative 1 squared so once you get
once again you get negative 3 plus 8 it
is equal to 5 so this is the point right
over here it is 1 comma 5 and then
finally let's do one more point let's
see what happens when X is positive 2
when X is positive 2 f of X is negative
3 times positive 2 squared 2 squared
plus 8 this right over here is negative
3 times 4 which is negative 12 plus 8 is
equal to negative 4 so when X is
positive 2 y equals f of X is equal to
negative 4 so this over here and you
might want to plot even more points to
get the general shape of it is going to
be a downward-opening curve a
downward-opening parabola we could call
it
and it will look like this and I'll draw
it as a dotted line just so that I can
just so that I can do a decent job of it
it's going to look something as messed
up those last few it's going to look
something like nope let me draw it a
little bit straighter so this curve the
main thing is that my scale off a little
bit so it's going to look something
something like that and so this point is
right over here I'm gonna have to make
these points a little bit bigger so they
fall out of my line but I want the curve
to look somewhat reasonable that point
is right over there and this last blue
point is the point two comma negative
four and if you're saying wait how do
you know to curve it just like that
using those points frankly that's just
from previous experiencing experience
knowing that this is a parabola if you
really wanted to verify it for yourself
I really encourage you to take out some
nice clean graph paper and plot the
points exactly and then you could even
try points like negative 1/2 and
positive 1/2 and you'll see that this
curve shapes out like this and one thing
you might notice is the curve is kind of
that the right side of this curve looks
like the left side of this curve that
whatever the positive x value we take on
the same f of X values the negative x
value and that's because in our function
definition whatever our input is we
squared so whether we start with
positive 2 or negative 2 when you square
it you get the same value whether you
start with positive 1 or negative 1 you
square it you get the same value and
that's why positive f of positive 2 is
equal to f of negative 2 and for all and
for really any other number F of
positive 1 is equal to F of negative 1